new at six tonight A Nevada Democrat is
proposing a new law to punish so-called
fake electors now the move comes after
Nevada Republicans sent a slate of their
own electors to Washington after the
2020 election as seen here in this video
I should say this photo uh the majority
of nevadans supported President Biden
now Democratic state senator skip Daly
says the proposal could carry prison
time and bar a fake elector from ever
holding office
I was
in disbelief
um you know that
people would actually try to do those
things and go as far as they did and
that's why some of the language says
that it's not only illegal to do that
it's illegal to conspire to do that
The Proposal would not apply to previous
elections however a spokesperson for the
governor says they are reviewing all of
the proposals no faked elector has faced
any criminal charges so far